today we're going to be talking about
how to keep your suede kicks super fresh
three steps to keeping your suede case
clean first one is going to be grab one
of these protective sprays like this one
from Kiwi cost about $12 you spray it on
outside ideally because it'll kill about
a thousand brain cells second step to
keeping your shoes clean and this is a
little trick we learned from Mark McNary
if you get a little dust or dirt on them
during the day you can rub your two
shoes together rub the suede together
and it'll actually generally about pull
it off and clean it and not ruin the
suede in the last bit this is you're
kind of like a nuclear help there are
these little suede cleaning kits they
cost about seven eight dollars in like a
CVS type store works really well except
just to make sure you don't use it too
much because it is actually kind of
breaking down the suede you'll end up
wearing a hole in the spot where you
just had a stain that doesn't help me
shooting at all guys that's how you keep
your suede kick super clean for fall
thanks for watching another how-to to
stay with me John Wilde I'll see you
next time